[Music]
foreign welcome to the very first design
competition where once and for all we
will decide who is better the Architects
or the AIS
each team will be tested on their design
skills rendering skills and the ability
to describe their work the winner will
be unanimously decided by our Discord
server arguments
uh hi
oh hey guys welcome
and to make sure human Architects can
perform at their best HP provided the Z8
Fury G5 a powerful workstation equipped
with 56 cores 128 gigabytes of RAM 4 RTX
a6000 that'll speed up any human-made
process thank you HP for sponsoring this
competition much appreciated the
competitions pull from different phases
of the design process and will lead to
the design of a 280 square meter house
on a hill
design a floor plan for a 280 square
meter house on a sloped terrain the site
is approximately three thousand square
meters at an approximately 20 degree
angle the house must have three bedrooms
and a pool and take advantage of the
view overlooking the hill so how many
square feet was that sorry it's 280
square meters what was the angle of the
slope
20 degree smoke
plan I knew we had the advantage our
strategy was to simultaneously develop
three different ideas since we knew the
next challenge is to create a compelling
rendering we would pick an option that
leads to the most compelling form
a challenge within a challenge
option one the cantilever with the
bedrooms on the bottom volume and the
kitchen and living spaces on top but
with volumes cantilever over the slope
with minimal Interruption to the
landscape the intersection of the two
volumes create a light filled
double-story Atrium that connects the
different spaces of the house
option two the fan like the name
suggests this option maximizes the width
of the site like a fan and creates wide
open views onto the hill we've got our
bedrooms which are angled towards the
Sun and living and kitchen spaces all in
one story but the pool right in the
center option three the Cascade this
option follows the landscape each volume
gets a unique View and the interior
spaces Overlook onto each other creating
a connection between different floors
each of the bedrooms get direct exterior
access with a pool jutting out next to
the Living Spaces
[Music]
please
[Applause]
[Music]
that's actually pretty good
all right we need to pick a plan okay
well I really like how yours sits in the
topography and yours looks absolutely we
need to pick one plan guys let's just
pick something that looks good in the
renders
foreign
[Music]
what the hell
oh wow look at that that's a crack
yo can you try to model this
yeah hmm yeah right there
that's kind of cool
Challenge number two develop the floor
plans into compelling conceptual
renderings that tell the story of your
building take into consideration the
unique characteristics of the site the
word compelling is the key to this
challenge
all right team so what's the game plan
so someone needs to populate the site
someone do the building at the pool
that's going to be our money shot no the
experience
all right I'll take the landscape okay
I'll take the building so Trisha you
take the pool
[Music]
okay that's really creepy the setting
often makes or breaks a render and
because we didn't have a huge amount of
time to spend in Photoshop nailing down
the context right in a rendering
software was essential because of this
we decided to use D5 which has thousands
of high quality models you can easily
plop into your model you can see the
changes in real time it's super
intuitive and you can render complex
scenes without a problem so you can
really speed up the visualization
process we lay down the grass and
combine different types of vegetation
that we felt worked in this landscape we
wanted to bring Focus to the crevice at
the center so the flanking volumes on
either side should be quieter a bit more
integrated with the site we decided to
use wood siding with the soffit and
balcony in dark metal after playing
around with a bunch of different
material options we landed on concrete
for the mass wall the pool is the money
shot the entry experience should be
Exquisite with the refraction of the
pool showering you as you enter the
house equally important is the view from
the top with the infinity pool
overlooking the hill
foreign
okay are you guys ready
[Music]
all right quick let's set up the views
nice
guys look
[Music]
damn
how about a video they can't do that
right
wait are we allowed to do that well
nobody said we can't okay video it is
[Music]
oh snow let's do snow
AI can't do video animations
right
[Music]
this is the last and final challenge
prepare a 150 word description of your
project
[Music]
now please wrap up all of your work and
package of thrust review the last hour
of the deadline is typically when
everything starts to crash however with
the HP Z8 Fury G5 we can have multiple
apps running simultaneously since it
came with 128 gigabytes of RAM that can
even be expanded up to 2 terabytes the
case is awesome too redundant power
supply 4 hot swappable M2 storage super
quiet cooling system and plenty of
connectivity the Z8 is the top of its
line so it's a little bit expensive and
might be a little bit of an overkill for
what you need but HP also has other
versions of this workstation which comes
at a much lower price point
check out the link in the description if
you want to know more
so over the last couple of days I've
been asking our Discord Community to
vote on these images I didn't give them
any background on the video or the
competition or who made these images so
the vote was pretty much based on a gut
feeling
but I think it's a big enough pool to
get a sense for people's preferences so
here's the results so the winner of all
three challenges the plan challenge the
render Challenge and the text challenge
was the AIS
and I think we expected the images to
have a overwhelming majority for the AIS
but we were definitely surprised by the
text challenge you should also keep in
mind that if you look really closely at
the plans that mid-journey generated it
doesn't actually make sense and that's
because mid-journey is designed to
produce pretty pictures and the way that
I ask people to vote is on a gut feeling
so they weren't spending a lot of time
observing whether the plan was
functional this was a really interesting
process because I think we're at a point
now where for certain tasks AI can do
them better than humans so the question
is should we be scared
is AI going to replace us
I don't want to sugarcoat things yes I
do think that AI will replace a lot of
jobs including jobs in the design and
architecture field if not now very near
in the future on top of what Dalia
Journey can do there's a lot of other
apps that we didn't cover in this video
like apps for generating masking studies
or apps for generating plan iterations
all of which we do pretty manually right
now this type of AI is called a and I
artificial narrow intelligence which is
the type of AI That's designed to solve
specific tasks really well and they're
only going to get exponentially better
every single year maybe at some point
we're also going to have ai for doing
construction details or writing specs so
I think the more specific and siled your
job is the higher the chances are that
your job will be affected by AI I can't
really get into the details of how to
situate yourself in this transition
right now but I did make a video on a
book that does break this down I'll
leave it right here but of course and I
can't replace Architects it can't take
abstract constraints and turn them into
functional conceptual and feasible
designs it can't coordinate the work of
other AIS and it can't take liability
for its work and it can't make clients
feel safe about the millions of dollars
in their Investments
there is another type of AI called
General AI or strong AI which tries to
replicate the full human cognition
and we are pretty far away from that but
once we get there we are pretty much
screwed I think my biggest concern right
now is how AI is going to influence the
next generation of Architects and
designers these tools generate what
feels like the final image and they put
out what feels like the final answer but
it's skipping a lot of steps to get to
that stage architecture is not really a
pure art it's a creative response but
it's a response to real life constraints
and these responses come out of a very
non-linear process of manipulating the
form see how that teaches the function
or maybe you can try to solve a problem
with materiality or light
it's a constant back and forth and back
and forth all with the goal of hopefully
benefiting Humanity even the very
beginning of a project is a very
Labyrinth process
and you can actually see how I'm doing
it with one of my projects right here
overall don't be afraid of AI try to use
it to your advantage and constantly keep
thinking about how you can mix your
existing skills with AI to create a
whole new category for yourself we've
been having a lot of fun with AI in our
office we've been using chat gbt for
research mid-journey for generating
thumbnails and storyboards by the way if
you're interested in getting access to
all of this background material that led
to this video you can do that by
becoming a spoon or a producer of this
channel you'll also get a step-by-step
process and a breakdown for each of the
design options that we've created for
this video I would love to hear what you
guys think do you think that AI is going
to replace us and what do you think the
future is going to look like let me know
in the comments if you enjoyed this
video please leave me a thumbs up and
subscribe if you want to see more videos
like this with that I'll see you guys in
the next video
[Music]
tragedy PT you idiot you don't know what
dabbing is you're embarrassing us in
front of the humans
[Music]